oh no there's the new guy okay okay what  was his name what was his name he told  me when we met what was it think hey I'm  Darius Paul okay Ben Darren Darren  Darren Darren yeah yeah I think his name  was Darren go with Darren oh no no no no  no no no no he's gonna shake my hand  Darren is so cool Zaki cannot mess us up  but there's so many possible handshakes  like the traditional shake the hand hug  the code of honor the slap and grip the  hug and grip the slide and pound the dog  pound the pounds of explosion in the  high five but if I remember correctly he  said he was from the East Coast which  means there's a 79% chances preference  of shake as the slap and grip so don't  miss his up sack  oh wait oh no no no no you had a weak  handshake bro so what it looks like then  okay my name is Ben Ben all right okay  I'm good one bed next time in you're  from the east coast right